Aurudubillahi mina Shaytana regime Bismillahur Rahmanur Rahim Allahumma saliya ala saydana Muhammadin wala ali saydana Muhammadin wabariq wa salam Kamasalaytawa salam tawa barak tawa rahim tawa tarahum tawa tawa tawa ali Ibrahim wala ali Ibrahim Fila alamina inna kahamidun majid Rabbish rahli sadri wa yaserli amri wahlul uqdatamil lisani yaf kahu kawli Assalamu alaikum wa rahmatullahi wa barakatu
In the last few sessions, we completed our discussion on these first three verses of Surah Al-Fateha Bismillah Rahman Raheem Alhamdulillah Rabil Alameena Rahman Raheem all of which are a testimony to Allah's abundant and consistent love and grace.
He is the master of everything that exists in creation and for that he is owed al-hamd which is sincere praise and unconditional gratitude.
Today we're going to look at the next verse which is Maliki yawmidin.
We'll begin with a linguistic analysis of these three words to get a better understanding of exactly what
this means so this verse Maliki yawmidin there are two forms of recitation for this verse there is the Kufi style of recitation which is what we recite generally Maliki yawmidin but there's another school of thought which recites this as Maliki yawmidin and actually both forms are valid so we'll look at both variations the word Malik
as we know by now it means an owner right even in Urdu the word Malik means owner and it comes from these three root letters mem, lam and kaf which is milk and the word milk actually means property so the one who owns property is called the Malik of that property
right now there's another word in Arabic that shares the same three root letters and that is mulk which means kingdom and the one who rules over a kingdom is called malik king so Allah talks about both in the Quran there is this concept of milqiya and there is mulqiya
The word milqiya means ownership and mulqiya means kingship.
And Allah ascribes both these attributes to Himself.
So He is not only the owner, He is also the king.
Because He is the one who judges, the one who decrees, who legislates, who has the ultimate authority over everything in His kingdom.
There is no one above the king that a plaintiff can plead his case with.
So, Allah says in Surah Al-Zumar, He says, Wa maqadar Allaha haqqa adrihi wal ardu jami'an qabdatuhu yawmal qiyamati was sama'waatum mutuyyaatum bi yamini subhanahu wa ta'ala amma'isharikoon They did not give Allah a just estimation that was due to Him.
And on the day of the resurrection, the entire earth will be grasped by his hand and heavens will be rolled up in his right hand.
Now, what does he mean by having it all in his right hand?
It basically means it's an ancient Arabic expression that actually means under his complete control, right?
This is milqiya, complete ownership.
In another verse, he says, Qulillahumma malikal mulk, tu'ti almulkaman tasha wa tunzi almulkamin mantasha wa tuaizu mantasha wa tuzilu mantasha, biyadikal khair inna kaalakuli shayinuqadira.
So, this verse begins by saying that Ulillahumma malikal mulk, declare that Allah is the king of all kingdoms.
Right?
Here he talks about himself as being the king, Malik.
So you can see that both forms are used in the Quran.
He is Malik and he is Malik.
He is the owner of the day of judgment and he is also the king of the day of judgment.
And both these terms have this implication that nobody will be able to question him about any of his decisions and he alone will pass all judgment
and make all the final decisions so that is malik or malik the next word is yaum which is actually quite an interesting word in arabic like maliki yaum iddin now generally this statement is translated as
a day, right?
Yaum is translated as day, owner of the day of judgment.
But linguistically, yaum does not actually mean a 24-hour day.
What it means is a time interval.
It can mean any period of time.
So yaum could be used for a moment.
It could be used for an hour.
It could mean a day, it could mean a month, a year.
It could also mean several thousand years.
So, it is simply a duration of time allocated for, you know, a specific purpose.
That's what a yawm is.
So, for instance, in the Quran, Allah says, ...
The angels and the spirit ascend to Him during a Yawm, the extent of which is 50,000 years.
So, here Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala specifies Yawm as being equal to 50,000 years.
In Surat al-Muzammil, He says, Yawma turjaf al-ardu al-jibalu wakanat al-jibalu kathibam mahila.
that moment when the earth and the mountains will convulse and you will see that mountains will turn into a heap of sand that is being poured down.
Here, he uses the same word yaum, yaum mater jafu for a moment.
So the word yaum can be used for various periods of time, including time itself.
So, in Suratul Fateha, he says, Maaliki yawmid deen.
Owner of the time period of deen.
Right?
So, now let's look at deen.
The word deen in the Arabic language comes from the root letters dain, which has several meanings.
One of the meanings of dain is, you know, it is a type of rain that falls over and over again until it brings the dead earth back to life.
Another meaning of dain is to discipline something.
Mandana nafsuhu, whoever disciplines his soul.
It also means a way of life.
Lakum deenakum waliyadin, you have your way of life and we have ours.
Right?
But the root meaning of the word 'Dain' actually means debt.
Our religion is called Deen-ul-Islam, the Deen of Islam and literally this can be translated as the debt of submission.
In other words, the idea is that we have been endowed with
innumerable and invaluable blessings by our Master.
And so for all those blessings, we owe our Creator a debt of submission.
Allah says, Afa ghaira deen allahi yaboon (Do they seek other than the deen of Allah?) Wa lahu aslamaman fissama waathi wal ardhi tawaan hawqarhan
while all creatures in the heaven and the earth have bowed down to Him in submission, willingly or unwillingly.
So what Allah is asking here is that do they seek other than repaying this debt when in reality everyone and everything in existence is paying its debt to its creator?
They're all in a state of submission, willingly or unwillingly.
Now, there are areas of submission that the human being recognizes.
One of them is our call to nature.
We have to do certain things that we just cannot avoid.
And one of them is, for instance, to eat.
That is part of our nature.
When we get hungry we must eat or we die.
We need to drink water when we are thirsty.
If we don't drink, we die.
We have to relieve ourselves once we have eaten or taken drink.
We don't really have a choice in these matters, do we?
We have to do them whether we want to or not.
We have to sleep.
When sleep comes upon us, we can fight it for a while, but eventually we have to submit or we go into acute psychosis.
So there is this idea of willing or unwilling submission to nature itself.
But then there is also submission to our own beings, to our own physical bodies.
We have limitations.
We can eat, but there is only so much that we can eat.
We can only drink so much.
We can only do so much physical work before we get exhausted.
Right?
We have limitations in our movements because of the structure of our bodies.
So there is a type of submission of the self.
given that we are temporal creatures that are limited by our physical aspects.
Now the Arabic word for a boundary or a limit is had.
So all of creation have hudud, right?
We are all confined within our limits, within our boundaries.
We cannot go outside those boundaries.
Water cannot flow upwards.
A rock cannot fly.
A bird cannot bark.
A dog cannot sing.
Honey will always stay sweet.
Citrus will always stay sour.
So in the Quran, there is this idea of limitations that everything is in a state of submission to its limitations.
Every creature is confined within its boundaries it's hadud.
and they are confined within it willingly or unwillingly.
So in other words, they are all in a state of submission.
And then Allah follows the statement with a reminder that they will all be returned back to their owner.
And to him is their return.
Now if you deeply reflect upon creation itself, you'll see that there are things that are emerging and then they are returning back into non-existence.
Everything that has life comes into existence and then returns back into non-existence.
Plants, vegetables, the animal kingdom and ultimately even the mineral kingdom.
they're all returning to non-existence after they came into existence.
So in other words, everything that is in existence is paying back its debt to its creator, except the human beings, you see.
It is only human beings who are not actively paying back their debt of submission, their dinul Islam.
But the difference here is that
We are also not being asked about our debts right now.
So when will we be asked?
And who will ask us about these debts?
Maliki Yawmitti, the owner and the king of that time period when the debt of submission falls due.
So Yawm al-Din is that time period when the debt of submission falls due.
It's payback time.
Qaifamma tu dinu tu dhanu How you transact with others is the way you will be transacted with.
This is why this time period is also called Yawm al-Hisab the time of accountability.
Rasulullah said in one of his Hadiths , he said, Take yourself to account before you are taken to account.
So there is a debt of submission that we owe Allah .
But then there is also a debt that Allah will owe us on that day.
You see?
When a master issues a command to his slave the fulfillment of that command is a debt that the slave owes to his master because there are only two possibilities he either obeys the command or he disobeys it in both cases a return or a recompense falls due upon the master you see if the slave obeyed his master and
executed his command properly, then his master owes him a reward.
But if he disobeyed his master's command, the master now owes him punishment.
That's Yawmud-Din, that's Yawmud-Hisab, the day when that debt falls due.
This is why Allah calls upon people to actually owe him a debt.
He says in the Quran,
Who will indebt Allah with a beautiful debt?
So Allah is asking us for a loan.
Why is Allah asking us for a loan?
So that Allah multiplies its rewards many many times over and returns it back to his life.
So in this verse, Allah is actually asking His slaves, Who among you will give me a loan?
Right?
Who among you will indebt me with His willing submission of 'ubu diyya, so that I can multiply its rewards many many times over and pay it back to you.
For He has the most noble rewards.
Subhanallah.
Even on that day of hisaab, this Malik is full of love and mercy.
So that is what Malik-i-Aumiddin linguistically means.
The king or the owner of the time period when the debt of submission falls due.
Now let's look at some of the implications of this verse.
The most important aspect of this verse is that it addresses this notion of an unjust world.
We know so many people today have given up faith and this belief in the existence of a creator based on the injustices that they see in this world, right?
They look at all of this injustice that goes on around in this world and they use that as proof against God.
Now this can be based on an injustice that happened to them personally or injustices that happens to another.
And their argument is that if there is a God that is so loving and caring, then how come He let all of this happen?
Now, what's interesting about that, especially to us as a Muslim, is that nowhere in the Quran, Allah claims or promises to give us a good life in this world.
Nowhere.
In fact, what He promises every human being is quite the opposite.
He says, in Surat-ul-Baqarah, He says, wala nabluwannakum bishayim minal khawfi wal jewari wa naqsim minal amwali wal anfusi wa thamaraat.
And no doubt about it, indeed, surely we shall test you with fear.
with hunger, with loss of wealth, with loss of life, children, with loss of crops.
But then he says, O Bashir Sabireen and for the patient ones there are glad tidings.
In Surah Al-Mulk, he says, Tabaaraka ladi biyadi hil mulk wa hua'ala kuli shayinu qadeer Blessed is the one whose hand has the ultimate dominion and is able to do everything.
Alladi khalaqal mawta wal hayata liyabluwaqum ayyukum ahsanu 'Amala Who created death and life to test you and see which of you is the best in action.
according to the Quran this world was never meant for justice according to the Quran this life is a test and this world that we live in is an examination hall and everyone is being tested some with poverty some with wealth some with sickness some with health in fact the healthy and the rich
are going through a much more difficult test than the sick and the poor.
Because they will be held accountable for these gifts.
You know, I gave you all this, show me what you did with it.
And this is why it's no surprise that the greatest man to walk the face of this earth, Rasulullah , he chose poverty over riches.
But the point is that this world is imperfect
and it is unjust by its very design.
So now let's take a moment to think about this perfect world.
If I asked you to describe your perfect world to me, if I asked you to design a perfect world, what kind of world would you design?
Think about it.
What components would your perfect world comprise of?
We will all agree unanimously that in our perfect world there would be complete justice, there would be perfect harmony.
No one in the world would sleep hungry.
There would be no disease, there would be no pain, there would be no suffering.
It would be a world where everybody is treated equally, justly.
Love and peace will prevail.
There will be absolutely no ugliness in that world.
There will only be beauty.
People would love and help each other.
The proverbial lion and the deer would drink peacefully from the same river.
Isn't that the perfect world that we all dream of?
Now if you think about it, what did I just describe to you?
I just described Jannah.
Isn't it?
Isn't all of this exactly the description of paradise?
So you can see that this world is simply one side of the equation.
The problem with someone who is only seeing this world is that he is looking at just one side of the equation and there are a bunch of imbalances on this side.
If you do not believe in a day of judgment, in a day of accountability, then you are simply left with a world that is completely unfair.
But if you believe in a day of judgment, all the injustices on this side of the equation
will get balanced with perfect justice on the other side of the equation.
So in fact, the injustices of this world is proof and testimony to the existence of a perfect world.
Logically, just speaking logically, rationally as human beings, what we see in this world, we have to believe because it is our innate desire to have this perfect world.
Where do we get this concept of a perfect world?
how come even the atheist the one who does not believe in God does believe in the in the dream of a perfect world because that is the other side of the equation so just this the inferior version of this dunya is proof of the existence of a perfect world so in this verse
Allah talks about this transition that will take place from this world into the next.
There is a transition from Rububiya to Malakiya.
From lordship to ownership or kingship.
From the love, care, concern and mercy of Allah in this world to the one in which He takes on a different role.
the role of the owner and the king of the day when the dead of submission falls due.
So this verse actually makes the transition from dunya to the akhara.
Inshallah, in the next session we'll look at some more implications of this verse
and how it affects our lives.
Wa akhir dawan alhamdulillahi rabbil alameen wassalatu wassalamu ala rasulihi saidana Muhammad al-Hatim al-Nabiin wassaid al-Mursaleen wala akhihi wa wassi ali nabi tali bashrafil wassiyin wa alal aimmatim zuriyatim mataibi natahin wassalim alayhi majmain al-Fateha